Transcription: Coline BUGNOT
Relecteur: eric vautier
Quand je pense qu’il y a des gens
qui ont des handicapés dans leur famille
et qu’ils ne vont jamais les voir...
Alors payer pour
en voir un qu’on ne connaît pas...
Ce n'était pas gagné pour moi.
Bonjour à tous. Je me présente,
je m’appelle Guillaume Bats,
j’ai 33 ans, je suis humoriste
et je suis atteint
de la maladie des os de verre,
plus communément appelée
ostéogenèse imparfaite.
Ils ont bien fait de dire
qu’elle était imparfaite.
C’est vrai que quand tu vois le résultat,
tu as un doute.
Tu te dis : « Dis donc, on ne serait pas
en train de frôler la perfection ? »
Alors, comment on passe de ça,
c’est-à-dire un mec qui arrive
à se toucher les genoux sans se baisser,
à ça ?
Lumière, projecteurs,
« Guillaume, Guillaume ! »,
attaché de presse, producteur,
télévision, champagne.
Comment on passe de l’abandon,
des familles d’accueil, de la DDASS
à parler devant vous aujourd’hui ?
Comment on passe des moqueries
à faire rire pour les bonnes raisons ?
Eh bien, je crois qu’on peut tout résumer
en une seule question :
vivre ou subir ?
Et ça concerne tout le monde.
Comme je viens de le dire,
j’ai la maladie des os de verre,
c’est-à-dire que mes os
sont très fragiles.
C’est une maladie génétique
et je suis né avec 27 fractures,
ce qui fait de moi le champion national
de fractures post-natales.
Pouponnière, centre d’accueil,
puis trois familles d’accueil.
Voilà donc mon parcours familial.
Je nais, je grandis du mieux possible,
sans père ni mère, ça va à peu près.
Puis les choses se compliquent grandement
quand arrive le jour où tu dois rentrer
dans le système scolaire.
La douleur physique, on s’y fait.
Elle fait partie de moi.
Je veux dire, je vis avec,
je ne la perçois même plus
en tant que douleur.
C’est une forme de colocation, en fait.
En revanche, être rejeté à cause de
ce que tu es, ça, c’est autre chose.
La douleur humaine, la douleur morale,
ça, c’est beaucoup plus violent.
Le regard de l'autre, ça, ça fait mal.
Surtout quand tu es jeune
et que tu n’y es pas préparé.
Ce jugement injuste
que tu ne comprends pas,
que tu ne comprendras jamais, d’ailleurs.
Quand au quotidien on t’appelle
le tordu, Quasimodo, Frankenstein,
c’est parfois dur de comprendre.
Alors tu avances dans la vie en te
demandant si tu as ta place,
si tu es quelqu’un.
Et avec le temps, le fait de ne pas être
respecté, d’être humilié,
tu finis par te dire :
« Ils ont raison.
Eux, ils sont ensemble,
moi, je suis tout seul.
Donc, c’est vrai, je ne suis pas normal. »
J’aimerais qu’on s’arrête deux minutes
sur cette phrase.
« Je ne suis pas normal. »
Avec mon regard d’adulte,
de personne qui a réussi,
qui est sortie de cette spirale,
je peux  vous dire une chose :
c’est exactement à cet instant-là
qu’il faut se défendre
et qu’il faut se battre.
C’est quand tu commences à trouver que la
vision que les gens ont de toi est juste.
Là, c’est dangereux.
Et à partir de là
j’ai compris deux choses,
que j’avais deux choix finalement
qui s’imposaient à moi.
Soit je subis, je m’écarte, je m’écrase,
je disparais,
soit je vis, je m’impose,
je parle plus fort que les autres.
À l’époque,
ma famille d’accueil me demande
de choisir une activité extra-scolaire.
Je choisis le théâtre.
Et à 12 ans, me voilà donc
dans un cours de théâtre associatif
avec d'autres élèves de mon âge et une
prof géniale que nous appellerons Gandalf.
Par respect pour son anonymat
et parce que physiquement,
elle lui ressemblait vachement.
Et Gandalf me traite dès le
début comme tout le monde.
Pas d’isolement, pas de peur,
pas d’exercices spéciaux,
pas de « Mets-toi à côté de moi »,
comme pour me protéger des autres.
Et surtout, pas de traitement
de faveur ni de passe-droit.
Et c’est cette attitude-là qui a
rapidement déteint sur les autres enfants
qui se sont petit à petit
comportés comme elle.
La magie a opéré.
Sacrée Gandalf.
Elle a regardé le mépris, la méchanceté,
elle leur a dit :
« Vous ne passerez pas. »
Si j'étais malheureux avant,
c'était à cause des autres.
Si je me suis senti mieux ensuite,
c’était grâce aux autres.
Voilà typiquement le genre de phrase
que l’on dit au quotidien
et qui nous mettent,
sans s’en rendre compte,
dans la position de quelqu’un qui subit.
En permanence, on cherche
des raisons extérieures
à ce qui nous arrive de mal,
et pire,
on cherche des raisons extérieures
à ce qui nous arrive de bien.
Et là j’ai compris
une chose très simple :
si je ne vais pas vers les gens,
les gens ne viennent pas vers moi.
Alors je change de comportement.
Mon rapport aux gens évolue.
Je suis de plus en plus
à l’aise avec les autres.
Et avec cette nouvelle confiance
arrive l’humour.
Cet humour qui va asseoir
ma place dans le monde et qui,
petit à petit, va dessiner ce
que va être mon avenir.
Avec cet humour,
je ne suis plus une victime.
Je suis le mec drôle, le bon pote.
Aussi incroyable que ça puisse paraître,
on finit par oublier mon handicap.
À 17 ans, les médecins
me font une proposition.
Ils me disent : «Guillaume,
on a une opération à te proposer.
Ça permettrait de remettre
ta colonne quasiment droite,
de te faire gagner 10 à 15 cm,
de calmer considérablement tes douleurs
et d’améliorer ton autonomie. »
Ils me précisent quand même
que cette opération est très risquée.
Mais à 17 ans, à cette époque-là,
j’ai tellement envie d’aller mieux.
J’en ai tellement marre de souffrir,
de passer ma vie à l’hôpital
que je décide de tenter l’opération.
Alors, en quoi consiste
cette opération ?
Paperboard.
Le but de l’opération,
c’est de me fixer
autour de la colonne deux barres,
comme ça,
qu’on fait tenir avec des petits crochets
le long de la colonne vertébrale.
Le but : tenir ma colonne
la plus droite possible.
Mais avant de pouvoir poser ces broches,
il faut d’abord étirer
ma colonne vertébrale.
Et pour ça, je rentre à l'hôpital.
On me visse autour du crâne un anneau
métallique qu’on fait tenir avec 4 vis.
Autour du crâne.
Une fois qu’on a fixé ces quatre vis,
on resserre le tout.
Grâce à un système
de cordages et de poulies,
Le premier jour, on me met un kilo
et chaque jour, pendant 3 semaines,
on me rajoute un kilo.
Au bout de 3 semaines,
j’arrive à 20 kilos qui me tirent la tête.
Le but de cette manipulation est de
passer d’une colonne comme ça
à une colonne comme ça,
la plus droite possible.
Alors c’est vrai que dit comme ça,
tu te dis que c’est plus
un truc que tu tentes
avec un pote dans un garage
le mercredi après-midi,
plutôt qu’un vrai projet médical.
Mais le gars qui te propose ça,
il a une blouse blanche,
un stylo quatre couleurs,
tu te dis : « Il sait ce qu’il fait. »
Donc tu lui dis : « OK, on y va. »
Arrive le jour de l'opération.
Ma colonne est suffisamment étirée
pour pouvoir poser les broches.
L’opération dure cinq heures.
On me remonte dans ma chambre.
Tout s’est bien passé.
Il est 15 h.
Vers 17 h 30, il y a un infirmier
qui passe dans la chambre
et qui dit au chirurgien : « Dis donc,
il faudrait peut-être vérifier
mais il serait pas
en train de mourir ? »
Effectivement, je ne suis pas au top.
Mon corps rejette totalement le matériel
implanté quelques heures auparavant.
Je fais une énorme hémorragie interne.
Mon sang compresse ma moëlle épinière.
Je suis en train de mourir.
Retour au bloc.
On rouvre, on retire le matos,
on me plonge dans un coma artificiel
et on se dit :
« Inch’allah, il va se réveiller. »
Effectivement, après trois jours
de coma, je me réveille.
Le médecin revient me voir
dans ma chambre.
Il me palpe, je ne sens plus rien.
Je suis paralysé.
Je rentre à l’hôpital pour tenter une
opération censée améliorer ma vie
et un mois après, je me retrouve
à espérer juste pouvoir remarcher.
Finalement, après cinq mois
de soins intensifs et de rééducation,
je retrouve l’usage de mes membres,
même si cette opération m’a
laissé des séquelles irréversibles.
Et vous voyez,
si on me demandait aujourd’hui :
« Guillaume, est-ce que tu serais
prêt à retenter cette opération ? »
Clairement, non.
Mais cette opération, à l’époque,
faisait partie d’une dynamique de choix
dans laquelle j’étais.
Une dynamique de me battre,
de ne pas subir.
Cette opération qui devait tout arranger,
finalement, m’a apporté
un autre combat.
Celui de remarcher.
Un combat que j’ai à nouveau remporté.
Et avec ce nouveau combat remporté,
j’ai perdu quelque chose
que je n’aurais jamais pensé perdre :
la peur.
C’était fini, envolé.
Et quand la peur n’est plus là,
tout est possible.
Je pouvais tout faire.
Avant l’opération, quand je voyais
des humoristes à la télé,
je me disais : « Ah ouais,
j’aimerais bien faire comme eux. »
Mais c’était un rêve.
Après l'opération, ce rêve,
c'est devenu un objectif.
Et là, je me mets à écrire
mes premiers sketches,
les premières vannes.
On ne va pas se mentir,
c’était de la merde.
C’était nul, c’était à chier.
Mais voilà, je réécris, je peaufine.
Ça reste de la merde.
Après avoir écrit suffisamment de merde,
je trouve que j’ai un truc
suffisamment potable
pour monter sur scène.
Monter sur scène...
Je n’étais pas serein.
Mais qu’est-ce qui pouvait m’arriver
de plus que je n’avais pas déjà subi ?
Me faire juger, insulter, humilier...
Alors j’enchaîne les plateaux,
je réécris, je retravaille,
je continue de peaufiner jusqu’à
un énième plateau d’humour :
« Le Fieald » qui, lui,
sera filmé et diffusé sur Internet.
Ça va provoquer mon premier buzz.
Ça va générer des millions de vues
et des milliers de partages.
Ce qui est drôle,
c’est que j’ai revu ce sketch
il n’y a pas si longtemps que ça et je ne
comprends pas l’engouement, vraiment.
C'était très, très mauvais.
C’était nul, mais j’ai continué d’avancer.
Les producteurs commencent à arriver.
Ce ne sont pas les meilleurs.
Ils me promettent Las Vegas...
j’aurai Dunkerque.
Bon, mais ça avance.
De là, je fais mes premières télé,
dans « On ne demande qu’à en rire ».
Tout se passe très bien.
Je rencontre Jérémy Ferrari, avec qui
j’écris mon premier spectacle.
Et là, tout s’enchaîne : spectacles,
télévision, tournées, festivals.
Et vous savez ce que
ce succès m’a apporté ?
Ça ne m'a pas rendu millionnaire,
ça ne m'a pas guéri.
Ça m'a juste rendu fier et ça m'a
apporté quelque chose de vital.
Chaque combat que j’ai mené dans la vie,
je l’ai vu comme une finalité.
Or, la plus grande difficulté de ma vie,
ce n'était pas de survivre.
Ce n'était pas de m'accepter.
Ce n'était pas de réussir
dans ce métier, non.
C’était tout simplement de m’aimer.
Et vous savez ce qui est le plus beau ?
C’est que ce nouveau combat mené,
je n’ai même pas eu l’impression
de le mener.
C’est ça qui est fort.
Dans la vie, c’est comme ça.
Parfois, on traverse des périodes très
difficiles où on a des problèmes de santé,
d’argent, de famille, de cœur...
Et parfois, on a l’impression
qu’on ne s’en sortira jamais.
On ne voit pas le bout du tunnel.
Et si on est plus fragiles que d’autres,
on pense même au pire.
On a envie que tout ça s'arrête.
On a envie d'en finir.
J’aimerais que dans ces moments-là,
vous puissiez imaginer devant vous
une boîte vide
dans laquelle vous puissiez mettre
toutes ces choses qui vous font du mal,
qui vous nuisent, qui vous abîment,
qui vous détruisent.
Fermez cette boîte
et oubliez-la à tout jamais.
Vous allez me dire :
« T’es marrant, Guillaume.
Tout ça, c’est des mots.
C’est plus facile à dire qu’à faire. »
Je sais.
Mais si vous y arrivez,
concentrez-vous uniquement
sur les choses positives de la vie.
Ça peut être n’importe quoi :
un goût, un souvenir, un parfum,
un événement...
Peu importe, ce qui vous fait du bien.
J’aimerais juste qu’à cet instant, vous
puissiez vous poser une seule question :
« Finalement,
elle n’est pas belle la vie ? »
Alors je le dis haut et fort :
soyez fier de qui vous êtes.
Et même si on me traite de prétentieux,
ce que je suis certainement,
je n'ai pas honte de dire
que je suis fier de moi.
Je suis fier de mon parcours,
fier des gens qui m’entourent,
fier d’avoir fait ce choix d’avancer
coûte que coûte
malgré mes soucis de santé, familiaux,
fier de ne pas avoir écouté ces gens
qui me faisaient comprendre
que ce métier n’était pas fait pour moi.
Soyez les seuls à choisir
qui vous voulez être,
ce que vous souhaitez
réaliser dans la vie.
Et si vous échouez, relevez-vous.
Je suis fier de ne plus me dire que si
les choses ne vont pas comme je veux,
c’est parce que je suis handicapé, non.
Enfin, je suis fier de faire
ce métier si passionnant
qui ne cesse de m’offrir
des émotions incroyables.
Et je suis fier et heureux d’être
avec vous aujourd’hui
et d’avoir pu vous livrer mon histoire.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)